à tous les salaires qui sont sortis des
salaires des animateurs alors on a on a
vu plein de choses on a vu que samuel
etienne gagner semblerait-il 600 euros
par émission de questions pour un
champion moi je me méfie toujours nikos
aliagas 27000 euros bruts par la mission
de ce vol c'est ce qui est sorti voilà
on est on voit là on a roulé roulé ça
parler les chiffres
mais chez si je serais sorti stéphane
bern 11000 euros par émission
je joue ma chère à castanet vous lire à
dire là tu voudras coûte donc moi je
vais rien dire mais je trouve que c'est
total aucun chiffre aucun aucun
sincèrement aucun chiffre mais bon il
faut arrêter une énorme hypocrisie qui
durent des années et des années
il ya les animateurs qui sont animateurs
et ya les animateurs producteurs ils
peuvent raconter ce qu'ils veulent
chanter ce qu'ils veulent aucun salaire
cyril je vous le dis très vraiment il
faudrait dire moi je gagne 1000 quand
les mecs prennent meilleurs salaires et
25000 en tant qu'acteur c'est tout ça
c'est une hypocrisie et crs et révoltant
moi je dis plus c'est pas un peu
d'argent puis d'entendre ce que ça va
coûter cher mais il faut attaquer l'on
nous prenne pour des cons
aucun animateur aucun de ceux qui sont
cités là et tous les autres je vous le
dis aucun salaire
si tu es né le vrai alors été question
la question tout ce que vous avez et
animateur sur tf1 par exemple
voilà un jeu sur tf1 quand vous faisiez
un contre sens vous guette
j'aime bien sa gamme sur tf1 l'animateur
poids j'avais douze mille euros par
épisode
12000 euros par émission et besoin de
tourner cinq par jour
ouais ouais vous avoir 7 mai s'est passé
pendant une année non mais c'est pas
tout
on est content la journée qui fait non
jeudi par l'insee le pib de ce pays mais
surtout les années quand nathan et ses
objets d'art daniel habité chinois
non mais daniels sinon bah oui quand
même
rendez vous non mais non non je ne veux
pas jouer ça fait parce qu'il ya cinq
émissions ça fait plus de 100 euros par
semaine notamment il faut pas parler
c'est parce qu'en fait en france on peut
tout dire et son contraire on paye très
cher un jour de foot on dit c'est
scandaleux le mec qui fait vendre des
t-shirts qui fait 20 févier plein de
gens après cyril dingoo d'argent mais il
a une équipe il a fait 200 plus dopé par
mois donc il faut pour amener à ce débat
par contre il faut plus les journalistes
et il faut plus que les animateurs dont
on raconte n'importe quoi arrêter nous
prendre pour des cons
aucun salaire données ante où le suspect
donné c'est faux archi faux et fois
démentir voilà d'accord robert m'a juste
dit voilà c'est la vie de benjamin bouhy
après doha dubaï il faut quand même que
les journalistes puissante et d'avoir le
salaire des gens de la ville et on
s'était et vous aidez nous à les
bâillonner
ici je vous connais le nom s'est dit la
vérité et je vous dit rien
sauf qu'il ya aussi pourquoi soit
d'autre part les chiffres journalistes
parce qu'effectivement des condéens mon
temps on se fait aussi dire parfois que
c'est compliqué mais consignes des comme
lui des contrats sur trois mois sur six
mois qu'au bout de six ans sait pas ce
qu'on va faire on les verrait comme des
merdes tu vas dans une banque que tu
veux acheter un appartement ou faire
n'importe quel âge vous connaissez votre
heure pour te dis vous n'êtes pas chez
vous avait pas de contrat vous avez des
cdd vous avez rien pardon n'est pas le
genre de foot non plus n'ont pas arrêté
aussi nous cracher à la gueule mais
combien un peu d'argent on a des
contrats de trois mois alors les
relations ne vous cracher à la gueule
tout gagné l'argent soit si vous aime
pas
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la transparence mais c'est horrible la
transparence est faux c'est horrible
dessous savoir sur quelqu'un parce que
de toute façon forcément dissimule des
choses
moi je trouve c'est un truc suspect est
extrêmement malsain aujourd'hui de tout
vouloir savoir surtout en fait alors eh
ben merci merci de votre
[Applaudissements]